de la vaisselle des vêtements des objets
du quotidien
leur point commun ils ont tous eu une
première vie délaissé il aurait pu être
jeté
mais ici ils attendent de séduire de
nouveaux propriétaires souvent là c'est
de la surconsommation
je vois pas où est l'intérêt d'acheter
neuf si on peut trouver d'occasion en
bon état j'apprends écolo j'essaye de
recycler je fais du carton des meubles
en carton
on essaye de faire le maximum quoi des
fois on trouve des choses qu'on ne
trouve plus dans le commerce et puis
l'autre jour je voulais une simple clé
pour ouvrir les boîtes il n'avait pu
dans le commerce donc moi j'ai trouvé
ici à ma place les objets sont donnés
récupérés en déchetteries ou dans des
vide maison
certains auraient pu être condamnée par
un défaut mais ici il suffit souvent
d'une petite réparation pour retrouver
son usage d'un verre liquide pointe sur
une sellette et repartir à la vente
autrement c'est l'électricité un ou des
piles quelquefois un jouet qui a un peu
oxydé les piles sont payés donc un petit
coup de lime et sa part tout seul après
en cinq ans la recyclerie de
fourchambault s'est développé le cercle
des fidèles s'est agrandie grâce aux
petits prix mais aussi à l'envi d'une
consommation plus responsable il ya
tellement de gaspillage moi même quand
j'étais indépendante sans la recyclerie
je veux dire on va tous la déchetterie
on s'aperçoit que voilà une chose qui
sont jetés bêtement il fallait faire
quelque chose c'est que tout ça est à
une prise de conscience qui est là et
c'est très important
dans la nièvre il existe une dizaine de
ces recyclerie le réseau devrait encore
se développer dans les prochains mois et
permettre de prolonger l'existence de
milliers d'objets chaque année